Hello, I'm Craig Benzine.
Also known as WheezyWaiter, also known as Craig.
You don't even have to refer to me, really. If you don't wanna.
Do you want to know more about movies?
sure! We all do!
Well, you're in luck! Because for the next year, that's what we're gonna be talking about here at Crash Course Film.
I'll be leading you through the first sixteen weeks of that with Crash Course Film History.
We'll look at the complex, inspiring, and sometimes upsetting story of how movies came to be,
and how they evolved into what we now see at the Megaplex, or NetFlix, or on DVDs from Redbox,
or on Blu-ray, or you know, DVDs from
Best Buy, or you know wherever.
Because, as I'm sure you know, movies
haven't always look like they do now.
There was a real long process to
figure out what they ... were!
Were they spectacles? Documentaries?
Short films? If so, how short?
Long films? If so, how long?
Is black and white better than color?
Should sound be the industry standard?
'And where should we make them?' Because at first, Hollywood wasn't the epicentre of film making.
So many questions! And I'll do my best to
answer them. At least, a lot of big ones.
See, nobody really planned on movies!
They were an accident.
And most of the people that developed the
original technologies, even THEY didn't think
movies had a future.
Studying film is really studying people,
psychology, society, and technology.
What do we want? What do we fear, and why?
What inspires us?
Like many art forms, film gives us
a window into these things.
So, I hope you'll join me for the next few months
as we dive deep into the history of movies here on
Crash Course Film.
[Theme Music]